I was always picked last for like
dodgeball in school always I was always
like the boys were like she's so girly
she's gonna ruin it you know I was
always that reputation so when I started
getting these like action
tough girl roles it was really like I
don't know it really meant a lot to me
that that's somebody out there hadn't
seen that version of me saw me in this
land hello everyone welcome back for a
brand new episode of a Collider at
ladies night I am very happy right now
because I am sitting across from wait
for it for the star of final destination
3 everybody out there knows that I am
obsessed with that franchise so I had to
mention it at some point but no we have
one of the stars of Gemini man here mary
elizabeth winstead thank you so much for
visiting us today I think I know why as
good as you he is you you've made a
person out of another person
then you sent me to kill him
he made a choice to do this to me this
thing to here struggle what is fear
it has been quite a while since our last
year we were talking about a faults at
South by Southwest a while ago years ago
yeah I feel like this is like a big step
up from I think I had like a little flip
camera on a troll on a baby tripod in in
a lobby
yes I do remember that I'm glad it made
an impression so we're gonna talk a
little bit about Gemini man but also we
want everyone to get to know you as well
and the first thing I wanted to ask you
was did you always know you wanted to
grow up and be an actor or a performer
or was there ever a point in your life
when you said I don't know I wanna grow
up and be a doctor or a lawyer or
something like that I can remember being
like 10 and being like I'm gonna be an
actor slash doctor you know like one of
those really far-fetched ten-year-old
ideas of what being an adult is but play
it doc yes there you go see best of both
worlds but I always kind of knew I would
be a performer from as long as I can
remember I think I thought I I had it in
my head that I also wanted to like go to
Harvard and I wanted to get a degree in
something else because I wanted to be
well-rounded I had all these like
thoughts of what you should be or what
you should do and in my mind just being
an actor was somehow not serious enough
of a thing to aspire to be I think
because I came from a family of like
mostly academics and it's like my
sister's a doctor my brother's an
engineer and so I was a little bit like
okay I've got to have something else to
go with this but that as I got older it
was so clear that this was all I was
interested in but I ended up I didn't
even go to college I barely went to high
school do you remember what maybe the
project or the specific moment that
changed that mentality for you cuz I
know there's tons of people out there I
want to grow up and I want to be you
know something like in the film industry
but I mean even with what I do it didn't
really feel real I didn't feel like I
could be a film critic until it became
an actual profession for me I think it's
you know for me it took being able to
prove that I could do it on my own two
feet as an adult like I started acting
really young I was 12 when I got my
first like professional job and I worked
you know pretty steadily from that point
on up until I was like 18 and then
around the time I was 18 I sort of
struggled for a little bit to kind of
find more work and to find the right job
and to sort of figure out who I was
gonna be as an actor I was I was I was
having trouble trusting that I was gonna
work as a canoe
like as an adult and that was like a big
fear of failure for me because I was
like I just you know you just think no
you've gotta be successful at whatever
we do and acting is a really scary thing
because you just don't you just don't
know and I got I got lucky that I I
think it took me like a year it's like
18 to 19 I didn't work at all and that
was like I was like do I go to college
do I just give up what do I do and then
when I was 19 I got this movie sky high
which was like this Disney dude it's
heavy and that was like okay you did it
and then after that I never I never
really went very long without working so
I just I got very lucky
you mentioned finding the right thing
too and this is a little bit of a
convoluted question so forgive me but
that's another thing that I always
wonder about because especially when
you're first starting out I imagine it's
like like give you want to say no to
something give me all the opportunity
but at the same time you want to craft a
specific path that's right for you so
what was it like early on trying to
balance that mentality yeah I mean I
think I had very clear ideas of who I
was and and who I wanted to be as an
actor and I didn't always kind of know
how to get there or or quite understand
all the scripts that I was being given I
can look back now and think oh you got
that amazing indie script that like was
awesome but in my young mind I was like
oh I don't like there's a sex scene in
there I know you know there were like
things that I had that we're really
important at the time that are less
important to me now but that's just a
part of who you are and who you're
growing into and sort of going through
those phases were really important and
everywhere that I was and my career was
really representative I think of who I
was and what I was going after even if
it was like I felt like final
destination 3 like it was really she was
a really strong level-headed character
and for me as like a 20 year old girl I
really wanted to represent that rather
than you know the flip side of a horror
movie where it's like you're in a skimpy
skimpy clothes and you're running around
screaming you know that at that point in
my life I was I really wanted to be
taken seriously so even though I was
doing a horror movie it was important
for me that it was that kind of a
character
[Music]
big part of the reason why I'm such a
huge brand with a fan of that franchise
I feel like the leads in that one write
something about them always spoke to me
growing up more so than that's a lot of
us yeah yeah there's a certain kind of
inner strength in there so I would say
so
twofold question for you right now
because you mentioned maybe passing on
certain scripts that you weren't ready
for didn't appeal to you back that day
are any of those scripts actually were
they made into movie is now that maybe
you wish you had been a part of now as
an adult and also is there anything you
made when you were younger that now as
an adult you look back on more fondly
than maybe when you first did it you
know I can remember passing on the
audition for Mean Girls and I remember
it was partially because like my mom was
really when I was younger was really
involved in my career and so we'd both
read scripts and like sometimes she
would be like this that's terrible you
know like this the humor is like raunchy
or whatever and so she like hated that
script and was like you're not arresting
for that and I just sorta like okay
whatever it didn't really think for the
KBL definitely not for that role it was
like one of those like the Lacey Chabert
is wrong or something like that
Gretchen yeah it was for something like
that appearing yeah and I like I
remember just sort of lying and it's
probably not gonna be it's just like a
stupid comedy like what you know so
things like that that I just didn't
really I wasn't plugged into enough you
know I was looking for great roles to
play when I first started as a poster
really looking at the whole story of the
film and what the film was saying and
with the whole arc was um because I just
wanted to act I just wanted to like get
a great role to play so that's one thing
as I've gotten older that's like okay
it's not just about your character in
the movie it's about the whole thing and
everyone is involved and what the story
is and every every piece of it is just
as important as your piece of it but
that was you know I was a teenager so it
took me a little while and are there any
of those earlier roles that maybe at the
time you're like this isn't exactly what
I wanted but now that you have grown
into the career well beyond that you can
look back on it and say no that really
had something special to it of things
that I actually didn't I did end up
doing you know I did a lot of not great
work in my perfect days that I thought
was great at the time I can show you
some of my
early reviews it'll make yes right I
don't know I mean everything had its
place for me everything sort of took me
to where I needed to go in terms of
growing as a person in some way or
growing as an actor in some way even the
ones that were not great sort of helped
me figure out where I wanted to go
towards and what I wanted to move away
from so honestly everything was was
really meaningful in its own way for
that reason I like being able to look at
it that way that's true going back again
because you know I'm busy reading your
Wikipedia page to prep for all this and
one thing caught my eye that you are a
ballet dancer and that you stopped
because you're too tall so I'm just
wondering what it's like going through
something like that where you have the
mentality of like I'm super passionate
about this but there's something I can't
control that's stopping me from yeah
yeah and that I don't know that just
sounds so upsetting so I'm curious to
know what it was like going through that
yeah I mean I think I was able to sort
of numb it out a little bit because I
was starting to act it so I just went on
to that and I tried not to really think
about you know the fact that the dancing
thing wasn't gonna work out for me you
know I definitely had that like I went
from being like a 12 year old kid who
was perfect for the ballet world to
about Timo's 40 and I sort of like woke
up one day and I had hips and I was
really tall and I was just like my body
was totally different and so you could
just filled no I don't remember anybody
outright saying to me like you're never
gonna make it because you're too tall in
your butt but like the I could see by
the way people were looking at me it was
like suddenly like all my teachers were
like disappointed and it was like he was
just crushing as a kid to just walk into
a room where we go you know you could
just see it so I didn't really want to
be in that environment anymore
I dealt with it a little bit in the
acting world as well so it wasn't like I
completely got away from it but at least
with acting I I could trust that this
was some place I could continue I could
push forward I could keep acting through
the years and I wouldn't end up having
to sort of you know sit back at the age
of 30
yeah whatever it would be for for a
dancer to flip that around a little is
there anything that you thought I can
never do this even in acting earlier on
that you wound up accomplishing that I
mean oh gosh so many stereotype of role
maybe maybe something
you've done so much stunt work now and
yeah something really cool coming up yes
no definitely I mean stunts I think
probably as I when I was a kid because I
was a ballet dancer there was always
this association with me being really
girly like you know you know like I was
always picked last for like dodgeball in
school always I was always like the boys
were like she's so girly she's gonna
ruin it you know I was always that
reputation so when I started getting
these like action
tough girl roles it was really like I
don't know it really meant a lot to me
that that's somebody out there who
hadn't seen that version of me saw me in
this way now I want to see you play a
doctor but also like we got to find you
like a biopic about a pro athlete
seriously if you want to learn any
specific like even a sport or a
profession for a movie for a role what
would it think oh my god I don't know
why I just popped into my head but I
used to for a little time I rode horses
when I was a kid and I got thrown off
and I didn't really ever continue with
it and I don't know why that's the first
thing that popped into my head but I'd
love to like you know get to know
working with horses again you see the
movie the Mustang this year no see it
it's something else that's that is a
beautiful you know movie I'm also I was
telling you before I'm like a little
like OCD and I'm obsessed with the idea
of preset rituals just things you have
to do before you get ready to shoot a
scene or something you need to have in
your hand when you go to set so is there
anything like that for you in a day to
day basis
a ritual oh gosh I mean I think for me
I'm always like I'm always somebody that
has the sides in my hand when were
rehearsing and like like you said we
were talking earlier about security
blankets like I almost never need to
look at them but I always want to have
them close by or have them in my hand or
have it you know just because you'd hate
to be in that moment where you're
drawing a blank and like and then you're
going wait what's happening
yeah lost so it's almost never you
almost never really need it but other
than that I don't know I don't have a
lot of what do you do when you're
working with someone else and they have
that moment you know you just try to
power through it and you try to not be
judgmental about it because it's all
it's happened to all of us and you know
that the other person is dying on the
inside like I've almost never had an
experience where somebody forgets a line
or it gets lost at the scene and and
doesn't care and it's like whatever you
know it's like deeply shattering when it
happens so you just want to like just be
like it's okay yeah breathe we're just
gonna work we're just gonna go through
it and just stay calm and wait until
it's over I feel like that's the only
way to make it better and yeah anything
you say and make it work no good for
everybody
do you have any onset vices like I
coffee or diet coke yeah both I mean I
try to stay away from the diet coke but
I never buy it at home so that's one of
those things when you're on set there's
all these things that you don't normally
don't allow yourself to have that are
just everywhere so diet coke fruit
snacks
um like goldfish crackers those tend to
be the things that like when I walk by
the craft service table I'm like oh when
I end up taking something yeah I feel
like that's appropriate too because it's
not it's not like too heavy I get a
little pick-me-up the one movie I made I
got in the habit of our are crafty would
make this gigantic pan of like super
rich it was like date bread which has
like a chocolaty flavor to and I have a
major sweet tooth so every time I walk
past it yeah yeah it's like and when
they make stuff - it feels impolite not
that's how I always am I'm like I've got
to be poor they just made this it's so
true I've got to eat it and appreciate I
like using that so recently we did a
Collider spotlight piece with Kelvin
Harrison jr. and he stars and loose he's
phenomenal he was telling me that he has
gotten into the habit of watching
interviews with other individuals and
he's busy referencing all these great
comments that they made that he's put in
his back pocket so I asked him if you
could ask anybody else out there during
one of these interviews a question of
your own what would it be so I've got
one question from him to you right okay
he told me I would love to hear actors
talk more about how they balance the
relationship between directors and
co-stars and also how to be a lead
that's a really great question you know
I've actually been in that situation
where a director doesn't get along with
one of the other actors and you feel a
little bit stuck like keeping the peace
kind of a kind of thing which is a hard
place to be because in that situation
both people were great I liked both
people for whatever reason they butted
heads so trying not to take sides with
anybody trying to just like be there for
anybody who needs you and that's also
part of I think in this situation I
wasn't the lead but but speaking about
being a lead for me I've always tried to
do that is to try and be there for
everybody who might be stressed out or
might be a special especially actors who
maybe have a smaller role or haven't
done as much I've been there before so I
can kind of see it when somebody is a
little bit like deer in the headlights
and I really enjoy that I've always
really enjoyed sort of like helping out
somebody who maybe wants advice or
something it's kind of nice to feel like
oh I can actually pass something down to
this person you know so I like I like
that and I and I am happy when I'm on a
set where the lead is is doing that for
me or for other people it's sort of it's
a really lovely thing to see I didn't
really touch as much on the actors
directors with yeah yeah directors and
co-stars and co-stars did he mean I
think he meant because in so in Luce
he's the title character yeah but he's
got people like Octavia Spencer walks
around so it's this idea of you know
being the commanding lead that mentees
for sunset yes but also working also
being able to be a part of the ensemble
yeah I mean it's sort of like being a
the rock ultimately I think is what you
what you hope to be and and what works
the best you know the worst is when and
I'm sure that's not like this in his
situation but in some situations when
you have someone who's somewhat volatile
or somewhat you know unpredictable as
the lead it's just it really keeps
everybody on edge all the time and it's
really it's not where you want to be so
you kind of need to be and Will Smith is
the perfect example of this like he is a
rock of positivity and strength and like
just like Zen you know and that's how
the whole experience around him feels it
really carries carries on through
everybody okay I've thought of three
follow-up questions now let's see if I
can hit all three of them first one you
were describing before about someone who
is a good lead and almost like that
feeling of taking someone you know
taking one individual under their
is there anybody over the course of your
career that made that kind of impression
on you that really stuck with you you
know um I I know I've already just said
Will Smith but he you know he he doesn't
do it in a way that's like super
in-your-face like you got to be like me
but he sort of leads by example in a
really wonderful way and just makes
everybody feel really happy to be at
work and feel really valued and and you
know I think that's that's what you hope
to be like and never loses his cool he's
just like he shows up and you just get
the sense that he's just grateful to be
there every day and that's like that's a
really great thing to take with you to
the next project for everybody who
doesn't love hearing about that yeah
when it's like someone like him to like
all these opportunities and it's so nice
to hear that doesn't take him for
granted and he he has like a good effect
on everybody around him absolutely I
have forgotten question too but I'm glad
you brought will up again because that
paves the way to three at least what are
the technical challenges for you of
working with two Will Smith's in Gemini
man well there were there were a few
interesting aspects to it I mean one
just you know I'm sure you've talked to
people who've done motion capture work
and so that was my first time doing that
so it was interesting every time I was
in a scene with both versions of Will
Smith in the film we would shoot the
scene in a very complicated way we'd
have to shoot it so many different ways
you know it would be with Will and his
double it would be with Will and will it
would be with Will and nothing you know
it would be like it was just all these
different versions and then at the end
of the movie at the end of the schedule
we went into this motion capture studio
and we did all of those scenes every
single one over again so so it was like
it was just a lot of work on the same
scene in in various various ways I have
a million questions about that process
so you're basically doing a lot of the
material two times over so going into it
the second time do you have to re-watch
exactly what you did and put like the
same you know intonation on a certain
long it's a strange process so all that
matters in the motion capture part of it
at least for our film was was wills
performance so I was there to recreate
this
for him so that it was real but I was an
on camera at all like I could literally
be in my pajamas and it didn't matter
and what they did was they would play a
TV with the scene so that we knew
exactly the pattern of our speech and
exactly how it went and we'd have to
match it like we literally be like I'd
be speaking along with myself like
looking at will speaking like kind of
like an ADR where you're matching
exactly you know the sound so it was
just a very odd like in my peripheral
vision I could see myself speaking and
then I was trying to act the scene with
him as it was playing next to me it's
like a really sort of surreal thing so
seeing everything that he went through
to see a film like this through to
fruition would you ever want to get into
that end of performance capture you know
I absolutely would be up for the
challenge but it it's got to be hard I
always thought I felt for him because it
was like he's doing these intense scenes
in this absolutely ridiculous arena I
mean it was like you know golf balls
everywhere and he's covered in balls and
he's in a grey unitard suit and trying
to end with dots all over his face
trying to emote you know and I'm just
like oh god so hard that makes me think
so we play a game here called would you
rather and it's all like movie and TV
based questions so it makes me think to
ask you this one would you rather do
motion capture or have to wear a ton of
prosthetics I think where a ton of
prosthetics I think I think it would be
easier to still feel like I was really
in the moment you know as long as I was
in like a real space with like real
people even if I was under a bunch of
stuff in some ways wearing a bunch of
prosthetics could be nice because you
could sort of hot you're sort of hidden
under there so it's almost like you
could be really real because you don't
have to worry about what's happening I
like the excitement of that I have one
traumatizing experience where it was it
was zombie makeup and I have a fear of
the dentist and they painted tooth rot
on my team and it was just like I know
freaky that takes a lot of time to get
off in general but the fact that the
tooth rot took so long to come off I
like you're never gonna come home is
freaking out but it wasn't gonna come
off yeah god forbid I would have to go
see the dentist I can't thank you yes
yes that's scary
so I also obviously have to ask about
working with Angley and specifically the
fact
one thing that fascinates me about him
as a filmmaker is the fact that so many
of his movies are completely different
whereas there are certain other
filmmakers out there that I know they've
got like a certain style or tell a
certain type of story so when you go
into a film working with a director like
Angley is there anything you could do in
order to prepare for that experience you
know he's just such a lovely and very
specific person you know and and in in
terms of what he wants to get across and
how he wants it to be achieved so you
really just kind of follow his lead I
mean I think ultimately what he's trying
to do in every facet of all the
different styles and all the different
you know types of films that he does is
he's really just trying to get at what's
most truthful like something that's
really truthful and trying to do it in
totally different ways like he's done it
in Brook back mountain in one way you
know and now he's taking this pushing
the limits of Technology to also serve
that purpose I think he's really trying
to just sort of capture the soul of the
person who's in front of the camera and
I think he's trying to do that with this
3d technology that me really makes you
feel like you're there with somebody I
feel like this is a really big question
but I kind of want to ask you given all
the incredible people you've worked with
do you see kind of I don't know maybe
like a shared trait in the greats
especially having brought up a little
Smith and Lee and everybody else you've
worked with is there it's like some sort
of consistency that you see there you
know I would say it's a strength of who
they are and kind of knowing knowing who
they are and so there's no there's no
question in terms of should I do this
should I do that yeah you don't ever see
that in any of them I mean Ann could get
like stressed out sometimes you know and
trying to achieve his vision but he
always knew what it was you know there's
no waffling and the same with like
Quentin Tarantino and Will Smith and
anyone like that they're just so solid
in their own sense of self which i think
is really amazing I'm so curious what is
it like when Angley gets stressed out
like I can't even picture it it's kind
of great it's kind of I just love him I
just really love just think he's I think
everything about him is so endearing so
sometimes he would get you know be long
hours and we're doing this crazy really
stuff that hasn't been done in film
before and that keeps truly trying to
push push these new these new limits of
Technology and
there'd be days where you just be like
pulling his hair out but he was always
like the next day he'd come out I'm so
sorry
I'm so sorry I got stressed out it's
like it's okay it's okay he's just so
sweet that you know some directors they
might get angry or you know my gosh you
don't get an apology from them like if
he ever got a little stressed he would
be so he'd be so wounded in feeling like
he might have hurt your feelings or
something so he's just he's just totally
lovely and when the stress is handled
that way I always think it's good it's a
good thing for someone to get stressed
because it means they care yeah maybe
you should work somewhere else he's so
passionate about wanting wanting this to
come to light this sort of these new
ideas that he has and I think it's
really wonderful so we are of course
sitting on the set of Collider ladies
night so I do have to ask about birds of
prey I know the rules no specifics but I
do really want to know what it's like
working on the set of a film where you
were working entirely with a female
ensemble with a director like Cathy at
the helm can you feel the difference on
a set like that it was so much fun and
yeah you totally can I mean it was just
so easy
there was no ego in any of it I mean not
to say that you go as a male only trait
it's certainly not but in this case it
was just so easy everybody just wanted
to be there I wanted to be with each
other wanted to be playing these roles
and it was exciting it was exciting like
everything about it was so cool like the
costumes and and Kathy like really being
at the helm of it and really making
these decisions like that she thought
were cool as opposed to going well we
got to appeal to this person I got a
peel of that person we got it it was
really like she had the reins and that
Margo was super involved in a
collaborative way but it was all just
like what do we think is cool like not
how we not like but our guys can I think
this is sexy or is that you know that we
didn't have any of those questions it
was just like what do we think is cool
so one question that I find myself
asking quite a bit now is to name
somebody that you think is changing the
industry for the better and one of the
names I go to often is Margot Robbie
because I just love seeing people who
maybe hit it big through a particular
role but then they swing that weight
around in order to get projects made a
way they might not have been made yeah
so what is it like working with her and
how
hands-on is she on a daily basis yeah I
would say her as well I think it's so
important for people that have a
platform like her to be making the kinds
of choices that she's making and to be
making sure that she works with women
and people of all different ethnicities
and backgrounds and and being able to
say oh I have the opportunity to get
films made now I'm gonna I'm gonna use
that to make sure people have a voice
who didn't have it before I think she's
absolutely going down that road and also
isn't just making smart choices in terms
of making good films and picking
talented people to to sort of share her
time with so I think she's on an amazing
track and I and I hope more people
follow suit I think the more names we
can add to the answer of that question
the better so is there anybody else that
comes to mind that you wanting in that
title to gosh there's so many people
right now you're not restricted to just
one I know I'm like trying to think I'm
mainly just thinking people that I've
worked with who I admire rosario Dawson
I admire a lot for the work that she
does I mean I yeah there's so much I'm
sort of drawing a blank but I what about
someone like even for example on the set
of Gemini man who is someone on that set
whether it's a co-star or you know like
a PA someone who made a difference
during a day when you were having a
tough day yeah that's an easy answer my
stunt double Hayley who's Ben now she's
my stunt double on Gemini man and birds
of prey and now she's gonna be my stunt
double in my next film and she along
with the whole stunt team are just the
most supportive positive people and she
would always be there basically and it's
not her job to be my cheerleader but she
always would be she would just be like
on set nearby like anything like you did
so good you're doing awesome
just always and there were definitely
times on Gemini man where I felt like I
just screwed that up like we have this
big long one er where I had to like a
reload a gun and I was like all these
guys falling from rooftops and it was
just like oh my god like you're really
in a firefight and I just was like I
felt like I wasn't I wasn't good I
wasn't on and she just was like so like
you're doing amazing she calmed me down
and
really talked me through it and I was so
so appreciate only someone you want to
keep working with yes yes she's amazing
so as we have to wind down here we love
wrapping things up with Collado random
questions and I've got no list here I'm
just gonna say whatever comes to my mind
first what is the most spontaneous thing
you've done recently my life is pretty
spontaneous I did a road trip this
summer through New England which was
really great and stayed in a different
town every night didn't plan it or
anything and then spent three weeks in a
little tiny town in Maine and just again
no plans just sort of like found a place
to stay
oh my god I have such a rigid schedule I
envy you so my know it was very lucky
I'm gonna have to do it because just
sort of have this little window of time
between projects I was sort of like just
go and do nothing for a little bit but
it was really great what is your biggest
fear biggest fear it's it well it
doesn't have to be deep like I never
mind of the dentist and bees and yeah
yes yes I mean I guess I don't i s I'm a
kind of afraid of heights I'm a bit of a
heights are probably of all those kind
of phobias Heights are the only thing
that really like when I see somebody
rock climbing on TV or something I get
physically ill okay so I guess you
didn't watch free solo oh my god
phenomenal and the visuals like yeah you
can't really shake that you could feel
like my cell phones will get sweaty just
watching it all right yeah maybe just
don't see that me continue to recommend
it to people because it is great it's
enough you got the opportunity to
revisit any of your past roles and a
sequel prequel you name it what would it
be and why um oh you know maybe it would
be Ramona Flowers I think it would be
interesting to see like where she is ten
years later I'd be totally open to the
character like I just think that would
be an interesting exploration
[Music]
Scott Pilgrim said you want to go out
sometime
no that's okay have you ever just
envisioned that especially while you
were making a movie like yeah who ever
think about you know where would she be
right after the story right I'm kind of
thinking about it for the first time
right now I mean we definitely talked
about ooh there should be a sequel you
know all that stuff was talked about for
years but you just think of it as like
what's happening the next day not what's
happening in ten years so I think for
all of those characters they're such you
know specifically mid-20s slackers you
know so like where are they now I think
that would be really I'm the sound of
that I would see a sequel to that movie
in a Hartnett I wish we could make that
happen
yeah pets I do I have a little dog named
Brosius and that's what I'm making a sad
face because she had to give her to my
sister for the next several months cuz
I'm gonna be a wayward Alisha's with
family yes I know but it breaks what my
cat has a cat sitter the like the only
person in the world a cat sitter that
comes and visits him two times a day
what am I gonna film fest that is that's
love dumi is a king and I live to serve
I have a million more questions but
thank you so until next time you are
obviously extremely busy so I'm sure we
will have you in for another movie TV
show you name it sometime soon or music
yes that was another thing that I looked
up the name get to end soon well where
can everybody hear any music fun you
know what I honestly don't even know at
one point I was on iTunes I don't know
if it still is but but YouTube maybe
yeah I feel like that's an appropriate
place to search for something and you're
already here if you're watching this
interview so guys Gemini man hits
theaters October 11th check it out thank
you so much for being bait thanks so
much thank you guys for watching this
edition of Collider ladies night
do not leave without like and sharing
this interview and guess what we're
gonna see you soon in more episodes
[Applause]
[Music]